we got a black mermaid and they're
making more Pixar is doing a Rapunzel
movie no Rapunzel let down your hair
Rapunzel is going to be black which is
cool but the prince is going to be white
so that's going to be a little awkward
when he goes hey Rapunzel can you let
down your hair she's going to be like
you're not touching this
but it is horrible when you see
some real racism go down I was on the
bus last week black guys trying to get
on the bus the driver's like yeah we're
full he's like what I'm just trying to
get on the bus he goes we're full buddy
and he goes you treat me like this cuz
I'm black you're treat me differently
cuz I'm black I'm like man that is
messed up that someone treat someone
differently cuz they're black then
realiz wait a minute we all do that
right black guy says the n-word no big
deal white lady you say the nword I get
an erection yeah but sometimes you
should treat groups differently you know
if my white friend's getting wild I'm
like dude you're crazy you're an animal
if my black friend's getting wild I'm
like
dude you're
crazy